regardless of if you're pitching or
presenting teaching or sharing at its
core communication is often about
influencing and motivating others yet we
don't often take time to think about how
to hone and improve our persuasive
practices
today we will dive deeply into the
intricacies of influence I am Matt
Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I am super excited to get a chance
to chat with Robert cialdini Bob is the
Regent's professor emeritus of
psychology and marketing at Arizona
State University his research and
coaching focus on persuasion and social
influence he's the author of two
amazingly popular and impactful books
influence and persuasion and I have to
admit Bob is one of my academic Heroes
as an undergrad Bob was a guest lecturer
in Phil zimbardo's popular class the
psychology of mind control and after
hearing Bob's lecture I chose a graduate
school program where I could do research
into social influence
welcome Bob and thanks for pointing me
to a field of study that I have
continued to be fascinated by
well I'm looking forward to our
interaction Matt and look forward to
spending some time with you and your
listeners great let's Jump Right In to
get started can you define and
distinguish between persuasion and what
you call persuasion and what role does
attention and motivation play in these
Concepts
oh good question let's start with
motivation first which is the functional
component of persuasion persuasion
involves putting into a message factors
that motivate people to say yes such as
the quality of an item or its attractive
price or it's fit with the recipient's
values or self-image or the fact that
it's a the most popular choice among
their peers those kinds of things if you
put those into a message they motivate
people toward ascent
attention on the other hand is the
functional component of persuasion
it involves focusing people on that is
putting them in mind of
one of those motivators
before they encounter it in the
communicator's message
let's take an example there was a study
done with uh furniture store that had
its specialty sofas and for half of the
visitors to the store researchers
arrange for them to go to a landing page
that had as its background fluffy clouds
the other half of the visitors went to a
different landing page the content was
identical but its background was small
coins pennies
then the researchers gave the visitors
options of various sofas to choose what
they found was that those who
encountered fluffy clouds were more
likely to choose for purchase
comfortable furniture
whereas those who were exposed to
pennies were more likely to prefer for
purchase
inexpensive furniture
so whichever
motivator of behavior in this case
quality or price was made sailing it was
was brought to Consciousness before they
ever encountered the requests to choose
one or another of the kinds of sofas
directed The Visitors to the one that
was high in Consciousness was most
accessible to them at the time and
there's an interesting mediator of all
of this and that is that
not only did these visitors
choose more high quality furniture or
less expensive furniture depending on
which landing page they saw
those people who saw clouds rated
comfort as more important to them in
deciding what to choose in a sofa
whereas those who saw the pennies rated
cost as more important to them in their
decisions
this is absolutely fascinating to me so
what you can do in advance of actually
even issuing your message can influence
people by managing their attention
in some ways it's it's priming and
framing isn't it
it is it's what I call using an opener
bringing people's focus of attention
onto something that is nested in the
message that is yet to come
before that message is delivered so they
have been readied for the concept it's
become more cognitively accessible and
more important in their minds here's an
example that reinforced this idea there
was a study of a wine shop in which the
proprietor played either German or
French music
on the music system as visitors came in
those who heard French music were more
likely to buy a French vintage those who
heard German music were more likely to
buy a bottle of German wine
because things German or things French
had been made more accessible in
Consciousness and made to seem more
significant or to have greater import
for their decision
because it was high in Consciousness at
the time
this to me really expands what we as
communicators should be thinking about
when we are crafting our influential
messages so I'm thinking things like the
room in which we speak how we organize
it the images we put on the slides that
we might use are these the sort of
things you're thinking about that can
really influence people before the
messages arrive
exactly let's say you have a meeting of
people who are on your team and you're
trying to break through with a problem
that's ju has just resisted your
attempts to solve it you need to think
broadly about it you need to think
expansively about this topic rather than
stay located in the the frames of the
approach you were taking it turns out if
you go into a room with high ceilings
and big windows
that expanse of the environment causes
people to think more expansively and
creatively that's great I I wonder now
that we're all virtual or many of us are
still virtual if the the background
image we put behind us might be
influential I I think there's just so
many things that we could play with now
and you've opened up a a Sandbox here
that we can be thinking about these
things wonderful that's great persuasion
is really really fascinating to me and I
appreciate you you Illuminating that for
us
you know I shared that that you had a
big impact on my choice when I went to
graduate school but my interest in
Persuasion actually started when I was a
young boy I vividly remember my father
reading a newspaper back in the day when
people actually read newspapers in paper
and he was laughing from behind the
paper and I asked him what he was
laughing at he showed me a comic strip
and in the comic strip there was a
picture of a father with his arm around
his son pointing at a store that the
father clearly owned and across the
store was the sign going out of business
sale and the caption read someday son
this will all be yours and I was
befuddled I didn't understand why my
father found that so funny and he
explained it to me that the store was
perpetually going out of business that
it was a marketing ploy to get people to
come in and that was my first
introduction to the idea of scarcity and
in your book influence you identify
scarcity as a technique among others and
I'm wondering if you can take a moment
to explain how that technique works and
and how you've seen it used today
people want more of those things they
can have less of the thing that is
scarce rare dwindling and availability
becomes more attractive
and one major reason is loss aversion I
mean the prospects of losing something
of value are twice as potent in
motivating action
then the prospects of gaining that very
same
resource right so in
the case of loss loss is the ultimate
form of scarcity
it means you can't have it anymore
so people want those things that are
dwindling in availability or scarcerer
you know the the acronym fomo fear of
missing out uh that's essentially what I
think is a major part of why scarcity
works is powerfully as it does
so people can manufacture scarcity to
motivate action in the direction that
they want uh and and companies can as
well I mean if you look at eBay most of
the exciting action happens as those
auctions are coming closer and closer to
ending is that all correct
that's exactly right in addition to
scarcity you highlight six other
principles of persuasion
reciprocation commitment and consistency
social proof liking Authority and unity
and we'll provide some links in our show
notes to help everybody explore those in
more detail but I'd like to ask you to
talk more about Unity which is the
newest of your principles and one that I
think is particularly Salient in our
current cultural and political climate
what is the unity principle and and how
does it work exactly
people say yes to you if you can show
them
that you share with them in important
personal or social identity that is
that you're a member of one of their we
groups the groups that they
use the term we to describe to
characterize in other words that you're
not just
like them that is similar but you're of
them you're one of them and in the
boundaries of those we groups all
resistance to influence declines let me
give you an example there was a study
done on a University campus researchers
took a young woman who was about college
age dressed like a college student asked
her to to set up a table for the United
Way
on a heavily trafficked area of campus
and request people who are walking by to
donate to the United Way and because she
looked similar to them she was getting
some contributions but if she added one
sentence to her request she got four and
a half times as many contributions
so what was the sentence
it was I'm a student here too
I'm one of you and people don't say no
they don't they don't reject the people
who are of them nearly as much as the
people who are outside of those
boundaries right and I'll tell you these
these categories these personal or
social identities
can be ethnic shared ethnic or political
or religious or community
or workplace or even athletic team
identities I'll give you a personal
example I grew up in the state of
Wisconsin where the NFL football team
there is the Green Bay Packers so I grew
up a Green Bay Packer fan and a while
ago I saw an article in the newspaper
that said that two musical artists
uh
Justin Timberlake and little little
Wayne were both Avid Green Bay Packer
fans
and Matt
I immediately thought better of their
music
but more importantly
I wanted them to succeed more
I'd like to move on and I have always
loved your creative research
methodologies that you've used can you
explain for our listeners how studying
Hotel towel use and stealing from
National Parks helped you identify how
social norms can be used to influence
people
let's take the hotel study first I
remember being in a hotel room this is
several years ago and seeing one of
these cards that asked us ask us to
reuse our towels and linens right it's a
hanging card usually in the bathroom
somewhere on a doorknob or a towel rack
and it often has a picture of some
endangered Woodland species you know
snow owls or something like this and
asking us to reuse our towels for the
sake of the environment right and you
know I'm a persuasion researcher I'm a
social influence researcher and I'm
always looking for
places to study social influence and I
remember
looking at this card and saying to
myself you know how there are these
signs you see that say this space
available for rent or this space
available for lease on buildings and so
on I looked at that card and I said to
myself
this space available for tests
what could we say on the card
we can include all kinds of appeals
besides do this for the environment and
look to see which was most powerful and
so we did this with various hotels we
had the cooperation of the managers and
we went into hotel rooms and randomly
assign various kinds of of cards that
were the same except for the
recommendation please do this for
all right and the environment was one
please do this for future Generations
was another but the one that made the
most difference was
the majority of guests who stay in this
hotel have reused their towels
and that produced a significant increase
in the willingness of people to
re reuse their towels
but even more interesting
we got a more significant effect if we
said not just the majority of
visitors to our hotel have reused their
towels the majority of visitors who've
stayed in this room every year dolls we
got significantly more now
because
one the principle we're talking about is
the principle of social proof that if a
lot of other people are doing something
it validates the behavior it makes it
more correct but if those people are
comparable to us
staying in the same room now that's not
Unity that's just similarity here
they're comparable they're like us
right
well that makes their behavior even more
um
diagnostic of what we should do
foreign I have seen those signs in in
hotel rooms in fact just recently and
every time I think of you in that
research every time I put my towel back
up rather than put it on the floor to go
out I think of that research and how is
this related to work you did in the
Petrified forests in Arizona
so at the Petrified Forest that is in
Arizona it's a national treasure there's
a big sign that appears as you enter the
forest that uses this principle of
social proof in an entirely wrong-headed
way it says so many people have been
stealing petrified wood from the forest
floor that's endangering the Integrity
of the forest I know what the generators
the producers of that sign were
intending but they made a serious
mistake in telling people that all of
their peers steal
right right
so what we did was to go into the park
at different Pathways and put up a sign
that essentially said so many people
have been doing this it's problematic
for the force please don't be one of
them and on the sign there were a
picture of three people stealing wood
picking up wood from the forest
right that sign
nearly tripled theft yeah you were
teaching them how to steal that's right
that it was a legitimate thing to do
it was okay everybody does this right we
had another sign that instead of
normalizing theft
marginalized it
that sign said if even one person steals
from the forest it undermines the
Integrity of the park and we showed a
single person picking up uh petrified
wood that
sign halved theft compared to a control
group
I find both those studies very
fascinating and and they highlight
how we can leverage social proof and
Norms to increase the likelihood of our
persuasive success
it leads me to my next question because
in essence the manipulations you were
doing in both of those studies was
changing wording and images
I'm curious to learn your thoughts about
the role of language and wording and how
they play out in Persuasion does word
choice really matter
yeah let's begin with language
um it works for persuasion
let's say you have an idea that you
would like to move up the the latter in
your organization because you think it's
a terrific initiative that would help
all concerned but to do that you need to
get the the buy-in of your colleagues
before you the latter okay and what you
often will do is show them a summary of
your idea or a blueprint and ask for
their opinion on it to get their input
getting their input is very important
it's the right thing to do the wrong
thing to do is to ask for their opinion
because when you ask for opinion you get
a Critic
you get someone who steps back from you
and goes inside introspects to examine
the pros and cons and the critique that
he or she can deliver for your your your
idea if instead
you activate the principle of Unity by
changing one word instead of asking for
that person's opinion you ask for that
person's advice
on your idea
now instead of getting a Critic you get
a partner
you get somebody who's in it with you
you get somebody who's a collaborator
right and research shows that if you use
the word advice rather than opinion not
only do you get more favorable
evaluations of your idea you get better
input from them as to how to modify and
improve your idea
just by simply changing
one word
you
change the entire interaction and
actually
get more of what you were really looking
for that is exactly fascinating and it
all has to do with the associations
to that word the associations to opinion
are critique the associations to advise
our partnership
based
so we really do have to be mindful of
the words we choose to help Drive in the
direction we are trying to achieve with
our persuasion or our influence so
before we end Bob I'd like to ask you
the same three questions I ask everyone
who joins me are you up for that
pure excellent okay if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you have ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be
don't have a favorite go to
persuasive approach
don't think oh scarcity I'm always going
to use care don't think oh I'm always
going to use social proof no no you use
the one that's in there
you it's a Fool's game to think that
this the same approach will be optimal
across settings and circumstances and
populations no it won't
the way to be ethical and effective is
this is there truly scarcity here then I
get to use it is there true Authority
here science-based information that I I
have bring that to the surface is there
true popularity or social proof involved
mention that
inside your your message so there are
several components of what I heard you
say one is be aware of your circumstance
and adjust to it so so understand which
of these tools is available to you
ethically in the moment and then don't
rigidly lock into just one way of doing
it so part of it is awareness and then
part of it is making use of what is
available to you there
so let me move on to my second question
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
right now I'd say Greta thundberg hmm
she's overcome certain cognitive and
affective abnormalities Asperger's
depression to become a powerful
Communicator for the environment and she
lives her commitment to it leading by
example
and her messages are very clear and and
and moving as well
right he really understands what gets
through by stripping away the message to
its purest form
and my final question what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
credibility
ethics
and application
credibility ethics and application
can you give us a sentence or two on
each of those because those seem so
foundational and important
yeah credibility you have to be seen as
someone who knows what he or she is
doing has the background experience
credentials right to be somebody to
listen to
secondly to maintain the ethics of the
communication and the durability of the
relationship
you can't fool people they won't come
back
who have you ever been have ever found
yourself being tricked into something by
someone or a product service
Communicator politician whatever and
then would you ever listen to that
person again
oh absolutely not and in fact I'd
actively warn people against it
yeah so part of a successful
communication recipe is not just in the
moment but in the long term how do we
maintain relationships in which people
are willing to listen to us and follow
our recommendations and then finally
application we have to give people
a reason to listen to us that there's
something that they can now do with this
piece of information that we've given
them or this product or service that
will be of of benefit to them will lead
to positive outcomes for them we have to
show them that
well thank you Bob it has been a great
pleasure to chat with you and to learn
from you and receive your advice and
thank you again for the influence you've
had personally on my academic career and
for helping all of us to become better
at understanding the elements that go
into successful persuasion and
persuasion it has been a true pleasure
to chat with you
I enjoyed it man thank you
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn